>>> Well, at this point, you
have heard of chatgtp, and it is
a tool that can write everything
from research papers and songs,
and now it has passed the U.S.
Medical licensing exam.
It is the latest achievement
from the artificial intelligence
tool.
It had previously passed law
schools and the entrance exams
at the Wharton business school.
So Jacqueline, is this the
answer to the sophisticated
medical questions is one thing,
but how accurate is it really?
>> Well, it is surprising,
bianna, but chat gtp got right
answers more than half of the
time in the answers that we
typically use in the U.S.
Medical licensing exam.
This is what the study showed
that the chat bot answered
questions according to the
researchers with greater than
50% accuracy across three tests
that are used in the licensing
exam, and they said that in most
cases, it exceeds that it got
more than 60% accuracy, and that
60% is what they use to measure
whether it passed the exam.
And since it got 60% most of the
time, it passed or nearly passed
the U.S. Medical licensing exam.
Does it mean that chat gdp is
going to be our doctors in the
future?
Probably not.
Instead, the researchers say it
could be a reliable tool when it
comes to making medical
decisions, diagnoses or plans or
translating jargon to
understand.
That is the role we could see.
>> So no Dr. Chat in the future.
But it does not feel empathy
like human doctors, and we have
heard of medicine becoming more
personalized, so it could play a
specific role, but it would not
take the role of the doctor.
>> Right.
It could be used as a tool, and
while it can make a accurate
diagnosis, it cannot break down
how it got there, and how it
made the decision, and that why
we are seeing this more so in
research as a tool for
translating medical jargon, for
writing study reports, and for
drafting pamphlets, bianna, and
so maybe that is what we will
see in the future.
>> So after going to school for
years on end, we can reassure
the doctors that they are still
needed.
Jacqueline Howard, thank you.
>>> As the cchatgtp could improve
and go after your job, we have a
report on what industries are
already feeling the impact.
>> Reporter: What jobs are ai
coming after?
>> Any kind of middle manager,
accountants and bookkeepers and
oddly enough doctors who are
looking to, who specialize in
things like drug interactions.
>> Do you mean out of the job
or --
>> No.
>> Or that part of your job.
>> That part of the job.
>> Yes.
>> Reporter: That is the relief
that Americans are looking for
right now, the explosion of chat
gtp and ai platform showed us
that we could do a lot of what
we humans do at work, and
faster.
>> Will it take my job?
>> Yes, and no.
It is not going to replace you,
and someone who knows how to use
it well will take your job, and
that is a guarantee.
>> By 2024, 8 million jobs are
going to be displaced by
automation and technology, but
it is going to create 97 million
new roles.
We have seen it before in the
auto industry.
>> While the auto worker may be
displaced because they are not
as good as welding or painting
as a robot, there are 35 people
who have to be involved in the
creation and the maintenance of
that device that welds better
than a person.
>> That is what happened at
carbon robotics and the former
workers are building a laser
weeder for Detroit farms.
>> It is a direct result of the
auto manufacturing that we have
the skill set available to us
all in one place.
>> The laser weeder is operated
by a robot, but it is run by a
human, because it fills a role
that it is harder to find humans
they cannot find to do the role.
>> It saves time and money for
roles that humans are hard to
find.
>> Ai is more affordable, and
there is no composer or musical
artist.
>> It is taking food away from
families because artists are not
able to fulfill it.
>> Reporter: And Ortiz claims
that they are using her name and
art to train the ai.
>> It is feast and famine for
most of us.
We go job by job, and what
happens when there is a little
bit less work to go around.
>> Stability ai as it is called
says the student misunderstands
how the ai and copyright law
works and says that it intends
to defend ourselves and the
potential that ai has to expand
the creative power of humanity,
and the other two companies
failed to respond.
>> It is straight out of the
movie.
>> And can the robot write a
symphony, can the robot turn the
canvas into a masterpiece.
>> And the robot looks up, and
he says, can you?